griffin canning is who will take the
rock and roll on the mound he's four and
four five eight two era this stuff is so
much better than a 582 era and you can
see
what has happened the bumps in the road
in his previous three starts and then
prior to that he was really really good
and a fastball is lined to the right
side and that's into right center field
[Applause]
there you go
[Music]
[Applause]
nice to see him going to the opposite
field there
over the top of a wicked slider to me he
pitched to his strength there that was a
great slider not easy to strike out
carlos santana at all
2-2
there it is swung upon and missed
down he goes the runners stay at second
and third
that's his that's his pitch he's got to
go to you just got to believe in that
and don't
get caught up in between it's almost as
if it cut fastballs or slider you got to
stay on top of the baseball and think
wipeout pitch
with a slider
rolled out towards short iglesias flips
on over to fletch and they got out of it
griffin created a lot of traffic for
himself but it's just a zero
so they'll get brad keller keller
going up against griffin canning back on
april the 14th
beat the angels
in a new role as leadoff hitter this is
his 15th game batting first
and he hits it very high to right field
one pitch and one out
to right center field and dozier was
over in that direction
[Applause]
rendon is just one for seven in the
series but that one hit drove in a run
against jackson kolar in the first
inning on monday and
98 from brad keller
that was a
six pitch all strikes bottom of the
first go ahead brad
let it travel as deep as he could he
gives it a ride calvin gutierrez into
right field it's hauled down out there
by ward
shoots that one to the right side coming
on in wong goes into a slide after he
makes the play chest high
elevated fastball trusted it and it
worked very well
put a way out there by iglesias he
needed that eight pitch inning oh did he
ever need it that's how you right the
ship sir
he is homered in three straight games
for the first time
bounced off the plate and witt will step
on the bag and that is a double play
4-3
[Applause]
jammed
and whit will take it himself
so keller gets around a single and a
walk as the royals turn to double play
in a scoreless second
another change up dipping and diving
that looked like a split figured
fastball that's a clinic
[Music]
call third strike with a fastball that's
keller's second
he heard me say that he took a step in
shohei based it left field on a breaking
ball boy that was a beautiful approach
it almost feels like it's a win if
you're a pitcher in it here's rendon at
the plate and here it comes on rendon he
swings lifts and in the air into right
center field chasing after the
outfielders and that ball is going to
bang off the wall that's going to score
a pair
well he didn't hit a homer but he drives
in both runners it's two nothing angels
good at bat this fastball 96 on the
outer half of the plate and anthony
rindon just stays right on it that'll
bring up calvin gutierrez who's over his
last 11. and there's a slider pulled to
the left side shortstop has it and it's
going to be
no outs on that play and a runt's going
to score from third base the shortstop
iglesias tried to get to third base to
take care of solaire but he
couldn't get to him and
run comes in to score and it's a 2-1
ball game i think the angels have
tomorrow off they'll open a series in
phoenix against the struggling
diamondbacks friday and there's a liner
down the right field line in for a hit
over to play it is dozier going for two
is iglesias head first slide and he's
out tagged out
to end the innings he's tried tried to
stretch a single into a double
so a super throw right on the money by
hunter dozier
change up popped up canning's going to
go with stassi toward the dugout
nice play out front little basket catch
if you will i have no idea how you
caught that one
it looked like griffin was getting in
there and he said you know i'm getting
out of the way
smiley i don't know how i caught that
one either
each individual pitcher jotting down
notes in the dugout things to talk about
later
gutierrez nice play and throws out
fletcher
that pitch
would negate those numbers let's see
he went with the breaking ball firm i
mean
started off the play and just
disappeared great adjustment by griffin
after
out towards short played very
comfortably by iglesias
a little whirling nervous before he
threw in time for the out two to one
halos here's
iglesias to the right side down for a
base hit
for sure one scores iglesia is hurrying
on a round they will stop the runner at
third it's two bags it's an extra run
three to one halos see what wong is
doing here angels have runners at second
and third only one out
fights that one off base hit center
field here comes one iglesias we'll head
to the plate wong drives in a pair
angel's five royals one
[Applause]
swings and he misses that's a three
pitch strikeout good morning good
afternoon
and good night
to the patient carlos santana
santana lifts that one left field
justin's got a long way to go still
going slides upton with the catch
attaboy jay up what a play by justin
upton
broke his back rolled out takes a funky
hop long throw across the diamond
and stayed on the bag boy there's
an insurance run
the 1-2
little roller
in time what a play it is a sweep grab
that broom and go to work the angels
sweep the royals and do so tonight by a
final of six to one